Well at this course has a long history and a,
the,
the purpose is really to,
to a wonder with you,
uh,
about,
the potential effectiveness of environmental law.
And I really want you to imagine that,
uh,
we have no environmental law,
by the end of the course.
Uh,
I may ask you on a final exam to,
uh,
to design a new system of environmental law,
that would protect us against the problems that I'm going to run through with
you.
This is a,
an unusual course in that most law courses,
uh,
do not,
go through case histories the way that we will hear,
uh,
so that,
we will,
we will be reviewing perhaps a 12 or 14 different case histories of specific
problems.
We'll be taking a look at the statutes that evolved in an attempt to manage
those problems.
Uh,
and I will give you my impressions about how effectiveness might be judged,
how efficiency might be judged,
uh,
and also really answer the basic question,
which is what's worked,
what has not,
and why as a way of thinking about how we're going to respond to,
to a,
a,
a very new world,
uh,
in which you will face your,
your children will face a,
your grandkids will face,
uh,
approximately 12,
10 to 12 billion people,
uh,
creating a more demand on resources,
more pollution,
uh,
rising rates of consumption,
a rising rates of waste.
How are we going to manage these types of problems?
That's,
that's the really the essential purpose of the course.
You'll see on the syllabus that a,
I want to run through quickly with you,
uh,
that,
today I'll give you a,
an overview of,
of,
uh,
the material that will cover over the next several months.
Uh,
on Thursday we'll review principles and strategies and environmental law and
I'll give you a quick cook's tour of a variety of different statutes as well as
the,
uh,
decision standards that are embedded in those statutes.
Uh,
then we will take a look over several weeks at the problem of national security
in the environment.
And really what happens when,
when,
uh,
the military,
spends trillions of dollars per year,
uh,
in the world.
Uh,
what,
what happens to a environmental quality and the public sector is not been the
target of 20th century environmental law.
Uh,
but it has been a very important force in shaping the environment that,
uh,
we,
we now are coping with.
We'll look at nuclear experimentation and I've come to believe that a,
the atmospheric weapons testing program,
uh,
of the 1940s and 1950s,
really is a,
it's one,
it demonstrates one of the greatest success stories that we have in
environmental law.
Uh,
following the recognition that,
uh,
the radionuclides that were created and,
and,
uh,
blown into the atmosphere,
work their way into the stratosphere.
Uh,
they encircled the globe.
and when they intersected rain clouds,
they would to earth,
uh,
they contaminated the soil.
They contaminated the water supplies.
They contaminated also,
uh,
food,
food supplies,
agricultural crops,
uh,
and made their way to the dinner tables of everybody on the earth.
Uh,
the radionuclides eventually became embedded in human tissue depending on the
new Clyde to it would vary between bone or fat tissue,
perhaps the liver,
uh,
and pose a very well known threats so that we'll review that story because there
are really fundamental lessons of ecology,
a fundamental lessons of,
of environmental health,
uh,
that,
we've really forgotten.
We've forgotten this.
We've attempted to manage air,
water,
food,
uh,
as well as consumer product safety or large tracks of land.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
why,
why had these lessons that a,
we're very clear by 1963.
Why have we forgotten those lessons that just the purpose of that segment.
And for each of these case histories,
I'll be reviewing the specific statutes that,
uh,
that,
applied at the time,
uh,
and talk about how they evolved and,
give you a sense of how you would evaluate whether or not they worked,
uh,
how effective they were.
Uh,
we'll take a look too at a preparation for warfare.
It's not only the waging of war that creates a great environmental destruction.
It's also the preparation for warfare,
the training,
the production of weapons,
the enrichment of uranium.
Uh,
so that if you look at the 25 to 30,000 different military bases and
installations around the world,
you'll see extremely severe contamination.
Uh,
so thinking about how that should be managed,
how it might be prevented,
uh,
will also be the subject of,
of several lectures,
uh,
as well as sight restoration.
And so we'll be looking at a predominantly public sector issues in this first
segment of the course.
And then we'll take a look at the private sector,
which has been the target of most,
uh,
20th century environmental law.
Uh,
we'll take a look at global markets and the challenge that they pose a and
managing chemicals and,
uh,
the management of chemicals is a very tricky business.
And that,
that,
uh,
it demands a high degree of sensitivity about,
where chemicals are released to the environment.
Uh,
where do they go?
How do they move?
Are they persistent?
Uh,
where do they end up?
and how are people exposed?
Uh,
calculating the magnitude of exposure is really fundamental to understanding
what the risk is in most environmental laws are structured to manage chemicals,
uh,
based on this idea of risk.
So to understand the risk and to manage it,
you have to understand all of these,
uh,
intermediate issues such as where it was it released,
where does it go,
how does it get into your environment?
Uh,
and what are the likely health effects?
And the word likely is very important because it implies that we need to be
thinking probabilistically,
uh,
what's the probability of a damage damage occurring down the road,
whether or not it's ecological or,
or human health related,
so that it,
uh,
we'll be thinking about the different forms of law that I have evolved to try to
deal with this kind of a problem.
Uh,
some set risk only standards,
some are risk benefit balancing,
some or cost benefit balancing and more utilitarian in their structure.
Uh,
so what is the right standard to apply for?
Very specific problems.
Uh,
we will then take a look at a variety of,
of the issue areas,
including what I think of as industrial agriculture.
Uh,
the majority of our food is highly processed.
it is chemically dependent,
uh,
particularly on fertilizers and pesticides and preservatives and dyes and
different sorts.
So,
uh,
what does that mean?
Uh,
the food packaging industry is,
is increasingly of interest to me in my own research.
Uh,
so I'll share with you,
uh,
several,
ideas about Tao plastics make their way into your life.
Right now.
The synthetic chemical industry is dominated by the plastics industry.
It constitutes 70% of the synthetic chemical industry in the United States.
In each year,
a hundred billion pounds of chemicals are produced and released to the
environment and among all plastics,
among those hundred billion pounds,
uh,
only 5% are recycled.
So we are building up a waste stream that is coming back to haunt us.
Uh,
if I took tissue samples from each of you,
probably 95% of you would have a residues of ballet or [inaudible],
which are plasticizers in your body.
And scientists,
including Hugh Taylor right here at the Yale medical school is now recognizing
that these are very effective chemicals,
that exceptionally low doses,
part per trillion doses in sending a signal to cells that estrogen has arrived
or another hormone has arrived,
uh,
so that they are triggers or hormonal activity in many different species of
animals,
uh,
as well as humans.
So what does this mean?
Uh,
in one way it means that we're conducting quite a chemical experiment on
ourselves,
uh,
but also,
on future generations.
So what should we be doing about it?
How should we be managing,
uh,
the chemical universe is chemical universe,
by the way,
in international commerce includes about 80,000 different compounds at present.
Two to 3000 new chemicals are produced and released to the environment each
year.
And,
uh,
they take many different forms.
Pharmaceuticals,
uh,
plasticizers,
a different metal compounds in a millions and millions of different products,
uh,
so that,
these chemicals have no mechanism in law,
even in the United States,
uh,
to test what their effect is and what the risk is.
The risk might be too,
uh,
either,
environmental quality or,
or to human health.
So what should we do about problems like that?
We'll take a look at air quality law and particularly the concentration of the
clean air act on a really very few chemicals.
Uh,
there are six chemicals that became the target of national air quality,
a law and regulation.
This is administered by the Environmental Protection Agency and they decide
which chemicals will appear on their radar screen.
They decide,
uh,
what monitoring programs are necessary in order to detect where they go,
how they move,
how they behave in the environment,
and how dangerous they are.
Uh,
who might be at risk.
one good example of that might be diesel exhaust.
And,
uh,
you,
you may know that,
uh,
the older trucks,
the less efficient diesel vehicles,
uh,
tends to spew large particulate matter from their,
their,
uh,
tailpipes.
And,
uh,
this,
these larger protect particulate,
uh,
particularly,
10 microns in size and larger are visible.
It's one of the chemical threats that is visible.
It's a,
it's one of the easier ones to identify.
In fact,
with diesel exhaust,
you can not only see it,
uh,
you can taste it,
you,
you can feel it burning in the back of your throat.
Uh,
so most people understand when they are exposed to diesel exhaust.
Well,
one of the,
uh,
interesting,
intensive EPA was to reduce the particle size,
uh,
to reduce the,
the larger particles.
And what happened when the engine's became more efficient,
uh,
to accomplish that was they produced more but smaller particles.
So the finer particles,
less than one micron in size,
not thinking that these finer particles can be more deeply inhaled into the
lung.
They reside there,
they get stuck to the sides of the airways,
particularly in those that have background illnesses such as asthma,
Emphysema,
lung cancer,
uh,
so that these particles don't get expired.
Uh,
so that exposure becomes more persistent.
the danger to health is,
is increasing.
There's an interesting correlation and I'm not saying that it's a causal
relationship and an interesting correlation between the increasing number of
these finer particles with rising rates of respiratory illness in the United
States and in different parts of,
of,
uh,
the industrial eyes,
a world.
So that,
uh,
why might that be?
Well,
let me give you one analogy.
If you a,
if you thought about an aquarium and you fill that aquarium up regardless of its
size with softballs and then you,
you calculate the surface area of those softballs,
uh,
and then you took the softballs out and you fill the aquarium up with say peas
and you calculated the surface area of the peace,
uh,
being analogous to the finer particle size,
you'd find a,
a many fold increase in the surface area,
uh,
of the peas.
Then you would have the softballs and because the carbon particles that are
these core elements of particulates,
uh,
because they're sticky,
they tend to lock on to a variety of different organic compounds called volatile
organic compounds,
which are also regulated by EPA.
So that,
uh,
the carbon core becomes the vehicle for bringing a whole array of different
chemicals into your lung.
Very,
very fine particles in size.
So that,
uh,
there,
many times,
uh,
the absence of excellent scientific information can lead the government into
making decisions that are,
uh,
actually not health protective,
or environmentally protective.
Uh,
so we need to be very conscious about the importance of doing excellent science,
uh,
not just,
a science about,
uh,
where chemicals move in the environment,
but their effects on human health.
If you went to eps website and you look for the purpose of the Environmental
Protection Agency,
the number one purchase purpose that you see on their website is to protect
human health from dangerous elements in the environment.
Uh,
that's kind of curious.
Many people think of the environment is not being that,
that closely associated with human health.
Uh,
we'll look at food safety issues and we'll look at the rise of the organic food
industry,
which I believe is a very important success story in the 20th century,
particularly the result,
uh,
of the,
the,
uh,
food production act of 1990,
although there was a delay in,
in,
uh,
adopting standards for organic foods until not until the year 2000,
but the organic sector in the food market now is the largest growing of any
other sector besides bottle of water.
If you include water in,
in the food industry.
And this is a,
this is very interesting.
So the idea of,
of certification of government sponsors certification,
uh,
as potentially creating new markets for products that are health friendly or
environmentally friendly.
Uh,
we'll look at the strengths and weaknesses of the certification scheme.
not just related to food,
but also to,
to paper and forest products and a variety of other areas,
uh,
especially related to buildings.
Uh,
we'll take a look at the history of tobacco regulation and there's a special
legal paradigm that applies to tobacco.
Uh,
but again,
it's one of these types of threats to human health and environmental quality.
That was really a very lightly treated,
very lightly regulated during the 20th century.
And only now are we seeing,
uh,
the food and Drug Administration being empowered to take a tighter control over
the way that products are marketed.
Uh,
and we'll take a look at the advertising strategies of tobacco companies and see
a variety of similarities to other products such as toys or,
uh,
or candy or different kinds of foods,
toward children,
uh,
so that,
that,
uh,
hooking children early on,
to,
uh,
try to,
to cultivate their taste,
uh,
toward foods that are high in salt and sugar and fat.
Uh,
there,
there's some very interesting similarities between the way that the tobacco
industry was very anxious to encourage the youngest in society,
uh,
to try tobacco products knowing that exposures,
for very short periods of time could,
could become addictive.
We'll take a look after a spring break at land use issues,
we'll switch from chemical problems and pollution problems to land use issues.
And we'll put,
be a particularly interested in legal strategies for conservation.
Uh,
different,
uh,
approaches to set aside lands to protect biological diversity,
to protect watersheds,
uh,
in an effort,
to,
uh,
improve environmental quality.
We'll look also at wilderness and National Park Law,
uh,
and a,
a variety of other statutes that apply to the u s forest National Forest Lands,
uh,
the bureau of land management.
And we'll also look at conflicts between a land use and development and,
uh,
the important value that we,
we hold for private property rights in our society.
Uh,
we'll also think about urbanism and sprawl and,
and,
uh,
different smart growth techniques to try to control,
the,
uh,
rate of development,
in,
in suburban areas.
Uh,
we'll also look at the idea of environmental justice,
which really grows from a recognition of different groups,
different areas,
uh,
receiving or being exposed at a higher level to,
to either chemicals or,
or,
uh,
different kinds of environmental insults.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
we'll,
we'll run through a variety of cases where groups claim that they are more
exposed,
more at risk than others.
They're bearing a disproportionate burden of,
of harm or threat.
Uh,
and we'll also look at the rising interest,
uh,
and rising incorporation of Leed certification,
into us a national and state law.
So buildings are certified now to,
uh,
to,
be green at different levels.
Uh,
the school of Forestry and environmental studies building,
the new crew building,
for example,
uh,
is applying for the highest level of Leed certification.
It's called platinum.
Uh,
so we'll,
we'll look at the evolution of that certification scheme.
And A,
I'll be actually quite critical of,
of,
uh,
the scheme and the way that the standards are being adopted by different
governments,
uh,
that become the foundation for the allocation of property tax breaks.
Uh,
but also direct subsidies,
uh,
from,
both the federal government and state governments.
Uh,
we'll take a look then near the end of the term at,
at,
uh,
past the past and future of nuclear power,
and the statutes and regulations that surround a nuclear power,
particularly the statutes that provided a really large subsidies when compared
to subsidies allocated to renewable energy sources.
Uh,
we'll take a look at a variety of different emissions trading schemes and a
renewable energy policies,
uh,
and then end the course with way reflection across these different cases about
what we've learned.
So that's the game plan.
And I wanted to spend just a couple minutes talking about course requirements.
Uh,
the course is structured to have a final examination,
uh,
with 40% of your grade,
but also,
uh,
there is a paper or midterm auction,
that would constitute 50% of your grade.
And then a discussion section will be held each week for 50 minutes.
So everybody will need to sign up for discussion section and that would be worth
10% of your grade.
I'll talk more as we move through the term about the term paper option.
Uh,
there are four books that have been ordered.
A and a,
I believe are all in if there was one that was shipped yesterday and should be
in this afternoon.
David Kessler is a question of intent,
which provides a,
a really wonderful review of the history of tobacco law and regulation.
Uh,
Michael Poland,
the Omnivore's dilemma.
A good part of my career has been spent thinking about food quality and food
safety.
Uh,
so we'll,
we'll take a look at,
at,
uh,
Poland's work,
will read Dell.
So a book that I published just a few months ago called green intelligence,
uh,
that we'll run through a variety of these cases that,
that,
uh,
we'll,
we'll examine during the class and then we will take a look at,
uh,
Weinberg and Riley's book called Understanding Environmental Law.
So,
of course,
themes that,
uh,
I intend to draw through.
These cases include those that are on the back of page two are,
are the bottom of page two.
Uh,
how is law related to science and uncertainty?
what causes environmental damage and health loss?
Uh,
where should the burden of proof of causality lie,
uh,
on the public sector,
or on the private sector,
on the individual?
Uh,
so that,
uh,
understanding,
the idea of burden of proof is a fundamental aspect of,
of understanding environmental law.
Uh,
we'll also take a look at the importance of secrecy,
uh,
and the control over information or knowledge.
Uh,
so I think of this as being a really a,
a,
an analogy between the public sector and the private sector and the private
sector.
A secrecy is a very important component,
uh,
in that trade secrecy protects,
companies,
uh,
understanding of product ingredients or perhaps how it's,
processed or produced a or shipped a,
whereas classified information in the public sector,
uh,
protects sensitive information.
In both cases.
The idea is to protect competitive advantage either in international affairs or
in the marketplace.
So we'll see how that plays out in,
in many of these cases.
We'll also think about,
uh,
the principle of democracy and how participation rates vary depending upon which
law we're,
we're looking at.
Uh,
and as participation rights expand,
decision making becomes more complicated.
And what that means is that it often slows down and it's,
it's harder to,
uh,
it's harder to reach a mission of,
of improved environmental quality.
Uh,
we'll look at property rights,
uh,
and,
rights in law or an essential component,
uh,
but also obligations are an essential component.
So I,
I think about law,
I think about,
uh,
how rights are specified,
how obligations are specified.
You know,
what are the sanctions applied for for deviance,
uh,
and where does the perception of legitimacy for that law come from?
So we'll be asking those set of questions for each you the laws that we review.
We'll take a look too at the principles of equality and justice,
uh,
and,
spend a lot of attention.
Uh,
looking at a disproportionate allocation of burdens or damages or pollution,
uh,
were,
dangerous facilities are located.
I will also take a look at the idea of risk and precaution.
So what is acceptable risk,
uh,
once it's calculated,
how do you determine what is acceptable?
If you look across the laws,
uh,
the different statutes have very different definitions of what acceptable risk
is.
Uh,
we'll also think a lot about the idea of precautionary law as opposed to UTA
utilitarian law.
Uh,
so law that builds in safety margins or buffer zones to protect against a
miscalculations of risk.
Uh,
we did not do that when we built nuclear power plants and we've had several
severe accidents in the world,
and those notably Chernobyl that we'll take a look at.
Uh,
when we look at the nuclear power plant case,
uh,
so that,
thinking about,
uh,
when should the government be allowed to balance risks or costs against benefits
and when should a fixed standard of allowable risk a drive a decision.
Those are very difficult questions.
So that said,
uh,
I'd like to just briefly run through some of,
a set of slides here that I think are,
uh,
reflective of the material that we'll be reviewing.
And I wanted to start with this image,
the set of images from Thomas Cole,
a a well known landscape artists from the 19th century,
one of the Hudson River school painters.
Uh,
just to give you a sense of where I came from,
uh,
my background as an undergraduate was in history.
I had a fascination for English literature,
but,
uh,
also the history of art,
but a very specialized form of art,
which was a 19th and early 20th century landscape art.
And I was always fascinated by this series called the course of Empire by Thomas
Cole.
Uh,
and in the,
in the very first painting on the lower left,
you see what's thought of as the savage state and,
uh,
this is Thomas Kohl's,
a obvious interpretation of the evolution of civilization.
Uh,
so the savage state,
uh,
is wild.
Uh,
it's hostile.
I think of it in a way as being a wild lands.
And I've always had a strong fascination for wild lands,
uh,
when I was a child and my dad always took me camping or hiking up in the white
mountains in New Hampshire,
or the Adirondacks are up in,
uh,
up in Vermont.
And I always,
I,
it really caused me to,
to have a,
not just a fascination with it,
but,
uh,
also a love of it.
Thinking about,
uh,
how society might move from the savage or the wild state,
to,
uh,
the pastoral or the Arcadian state,
is,
is well depicted,
uh,
in,
in this painting.
And many people,
uh,
when they're,
they're showing a variety of different landscapes,
uh,
and,
if the,
the landscape's very between the,
uh,
highly dense urban environment all the way to the wild environment.
Uh,
they,
uh,
they prefer the pastoral,
the agrarian,
uh,
landscape.
Uh,
the consummation of empire is the,
the,
uh,
the next slide in the series a,
the,
the urban setting.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I also have had a fascination with,
with urban areas,
uh,
and have lived in Philadelphia.
I've lived in new haven.
I've lived in San Paulo,
in Brazil,
and in San Francisco,
uh,
and eventually settled here in Connecticut.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it's this juxtaposition that,
I find so interesting,
uh,
love for the wild as well as a love for a vibrant urban core.
Um,
and,
uh,
what happens in between in terms of suburban sprawl will become a central to,
to several of the cases that we look at.
Coal then went on to think about,
well,
what happens if,
if markets are completely unregulated,
uh,
destruction damage.
So we'll spend a good amount of time thinking about how to predict damage and
how important this is and the structure of environmental standards.
And then desolation.
And many today had this image of desolation a hundred,
200 years down the road,
uh,
in response to a global climate change.
So really,
uh,
this,
this set of paintings a structured my thinking in a variety of different ways.
Uh,
it made me wonder about what the potential of law is.
what capacity do we have to understand serious threats to the environment and to
human health?
Uh,
particularly over long periods of time.
what demands on science does that make?
And how can we use law to effectively reshape human behavior in a way that would
be more sensitive,
uh,
that would,
ensure that,
uh,
when we have 12 billion people in the world,
that we will have adequate food supplies,
we will have sufficient water.
Uh,
it will be equitably distributed.
we will have clean air and children,
grandchildren,
future generations.
Uh,
we'll have,
uh,
an environment that a,
they can be proud of.
I'm certainly not proud of the environment that my generation is leading to your
generation.
And that really is a,
that's the reason that I'm standing here in front of you today.
Uh,
I've decided to in my career that,
uh,
you know,
rather than working for government rather than working in the private sector,
uh,
that I would spend my life,
the bulk of my career training of future leaders,
whether or not you move on into the public sector,
the private sector,
nonprofit world,
uh,
to think I hope differently about a environmental quality and,
and how you might,
how you might shape it.
So the central questions here that we'll be looking at,
what's our capacity to manage environmental quality?
Uh,
what role has and could law play in determining the future of environmental
quality,
uh,
and what's worked well,
what's failed and why?
If we can't answer these questions,
uh,
I would,
hazard to say that,
that,
uh,
we don't have much hope of making a dent in the kinds of problems that we'll be
facing over the next century.
So the problem is considered in the course national security land use,
food safety,
plastics,
green building,
pesticides,
air pollution,
tobacco,
wildlands,
national parks,
coastal development,
conservation policies,
urban and suburban growth,
transport,
energy and drinking water.
In my mind what's worked well and why?
Well,
the nuclear weapons history I think is quite fascinating.
There's some wonderful lessons there about how we used a state of the art
science in the 1950s,
uh,
to recognize a serious threat to human health and how we intervened and,
and,
uh,
eventually,
how John F.
Kennedy decided to ban the use of,
uh,
the testing of nuclear weapons in the atmosphere that was resulting in strontium
90.
And the bones,
uh,
at high concentrations,
particularly among the youngest,
uh,
the children population control has been a success compared to the projections
of the 1970s by Paul Ehrlich and Julian Simon and others.
It's quite striking,
uh,
that the,
the,
uh,
a geometric progression projections,
have diminished substantially,
uh,
particularly in developing parts of the world.
Uh,
the phase out of chlorinated hydrocarbons,
including DDT and Alderman and chlordane and Dieldrin have to Clore back in the
1970s,
uh,
these became one of the very first targets of the environmental protection
agency.
And because they are fat loving,
there are Lipophilic,
they persisted.
They move through the food chain.
Uh,
they moved into a,
into our bodies.
Uh,
and uh,
you and I are still carrying around residues and many of these chlorinated
hydrocarbons,
uh,
your concentrations are lower than mine are a,
but your concentration is predominantly came from your mother via breastmilk.
Uh,
that's the,
uh,
the,
the mechanism of transfer across generations for some of these compounds.
Uh,
so phasing them out was a very important thing to do.
Lead in gasoline and paint a were phased out as well.
Chlorinated fluorocarbons,
uh,
that were,
and are responsible for diminishing the ozone layer that exists in the upper
stratosphere.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
reducing CFCs and similar ozone Goblin compounds has been a success story.
Uh,
at least at the rate of loss has been stabilized.
Poly chlorinated by fenal reduction.
These are chemicals originally thought to be beneficial because they acted as a,
a refrigerant and flame retardant for electronic,
uh,
technologies such as electrical transformers.
So that that phasing out PCBs that were building up in the tissues of wildlife,
a particularly large mammals as well as birds,
uh,
and also in human tissues has been a very important success story.
Uh,
recognizing the threat of as best bestest and producing a very rare form of
cancer called Ma Measle Thilia Oma,
uh,
was a very important step as well as the increasing restriction on tobacco,
so that we're seeing a decline in,
uh,
some forms of lung cancer,
in response to the tobacco restrictions.
And we're also seeing very interesting declines and the rate of addiction in
those parts of the country,
uh,
where advertising has been most heavily restricted and a public service
campaigns had been mounted to a warn people about,
about the dangers of tobacco.
Uh,
we've also made some great strides in the area of food safety,
particularly,
uh,
in,
in terms of reducing microbial contamination and also the,
uh,
the stellar success story about the rise of organic food.
Uh,
I think is,
is something to take note of and to learn from.
Uh,
so what are the most persistent problems?
The ones that have been hardest to deal with,
uh,
and why fossil fuel consumption,
renewable energy innovation in part to,
due to our lack of subsidies,
uh,
relative to,
to subsidizing fossil fuels as well as nuclear power,
a radioactive materials,
the concentration of,
of radioactive materials,
uh,
particularly for the production of weapons,
has created some of the most hazardous sites in the world.
So,
Hanford,
Washington,
uh,
the Hanford works in Washington as well as the Oak Ridge laboratory or a Savanna
river in Georgia.
These are seriously contaminated sites.
A waste management has also been a persistent problem.
Our recycling efforts of clearly failed us.
Most people don't know the difference between a plastic that is stamped with a
number six and a plastic that is stamped with a three.
And,
uh,
I'll be,
in fact,
I'll,
uh,
challenge you right now to go through one week of this term without buying any
plastic,
uh,
and,
if anybody is capable of doing that by the end of the term,
um,
I will take you out for lunch.
Uh,
I've,
I've made that offer for the past five years and,
uh,
I've not spent one dime on lunch.
Uh,
uh,
as a result,
transport to a personal transport as opposed to a public transit facilities is a
persistent and growing problem.
Uh,
we now have one vehicle in the United States for every person who is eligible to
drive.
That's nearly 250 million vehicles.
We have more vehicles per capita in the United States than any other place in
the world.
And we ma,
we drive more miles per person than any place in the world.
Uh,
the,
uh,
failure to develop public transit facilities is quite striking,
parks and protected areas.
And we are not protecting areas the way that we were back in the 1970s in the
1980s.
So why are we slowed down?
Why was the government,
uh,
in the process of acquiring lands in the 1960s,
70s and 80s,
uh,
and,
building parks and building large corridors for wildlife to conserve biological
diversity,
but also to provide widescale recreational opportunities.
So why of the why of land acquisition efforts been installed?
Uh,
biological diversity loss,
uh,
is also growing in part because of the chemical threats that I described earlier
in the lecture.
There are nearly 450 million acres of the United StatesStates' landscape that
are routinely sprayed by biocides,
pesticides,
uh,
of one sort or another.
There are a thousand different biocides that are each licensed independently.
Uh,
so at that scale,
uh,
how could we not think that we would be threatening different species?
Also,
agriculture,
uh,
one of the great drivers of loss of biological diversity in the world is
agricultural development.
Uh,
and you can see this in the Amazon,
uh,
where tropical rain forests that are some of the richest and most biologically
diverse ecosystems in the world are being ripped up and planted with soybeans,
uh,
for either food or fuel production.
So we'll,
we'll take a look at,
uh,
some of the key drivers behind biodiversity loss,
a marine species exploitation.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll take a look at the decline of a variety of commercial fish.
Uh,
we'll also be taking a look at,
uh,
the,
tendency about large,
the tendency of large predatory fish to absorb mercury.
Uh,
so mercury is emitted from power plants.
It's also emitted from incinerators.
It goes into global circulation,
just like a DVT would.
It also rains down on the earth,
uh,
and it bioaccumulates,
in large predatory fish,
uh,
by the end of the term you'll understand which fish,
are safe and which are not and why.
And,
uh,
you'll also questioned the,
the Bush administration's decision,
uh,
to lighten the regulation on mercury emissions,
and how dangerous that,
uh,
has become,
particularly for the youngest.
And Society will take a look at indoor air quality.
And a one aspect of,
of,
uh,
this issue that I'm quite,
quite interested in is,
uh,
the environmental protection agency spends probably 95 to 98% of its time and
budget.
Thinking about the environment as being the outdoor environment,
whereas we in the United States now spend on average,
more than 90% of our time indoors.
And as somebody that,
uh,
is a dad and,
and cares about the future of,
of the environment and human health,
uh,
that,
that's got me worried.
People are spending less time outside,
uh,
there experiencing nature,
at a lower rate than ever before.
Uh,
they are spending more time in front of computers,
in indoor environments than ever before.
Uh,
and EPA does not do much to regulate the environmental quality of indoor
environments.
Uh,
so the,
the reasons for that are,
are,
uh,
sometimes,
obvious and sometimes not a one clearly is a respect for privacy and private
property rights,
uh,
but it means that that,
anybody is allowed to carry a chemicals into the indoor environment,
including cleansers or pesticides or plastics that can get into their bodies.
Uh,
and there is basically no regulation to prevent that,
a hazardous sites.
The,
uh,
the,
the number of hazardous sites now in the United States is,
is,
uh,
more than 350,000 on EPA list.
There are 50,000 different hazardous sites that have been severely contaminated,
uh,
that are under the jurisdiction,
meaning the responsibility of the Department of Defense,
the Department of Energy,
and the Department of the interior.
There are 340,000 sites that are owned in the private sector that had been
classified by EPA as hazardous.
So the rate of cleanup of these sites,
uh,
is,
is not even a 1% of,
uh,
the rate of discovery of new hazardous sites.
So this problem,
uh,
basically,
disregarding the chemical abuse of the landscape,
uh,
feeling comfortable to throw a chemical mixtures out out the back door,
without concern for their persistence and movement.
Uh,
this is something that a,
your generation will have to deal with.
A product labeling will also be a subject that we'll take on.
Uh,
basically if,
if you look carefully at product labels,
uh,
you'll claims of product effectiveness,
product,
uh,
appeal a associated with,
with,
uh,
color or,
or a functionality,
uh,
you will not see much in the way of claims or,
a demonstration of hazard or,
or guidance about how you might manage the hazards.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
product labeling could be an effective way of conveying information to the
public to inform consumers to make choices that are more responsible.
So how should we adjust product labeling law in a way that makes sense?
I asked this question with respect to pesticides several years ago and found
something quite interesting.
You look at a pesticide bag,
for example,
a fertilizer bag in a,
say a home depot,
a you'll see the green lawn with the children playing on the lawn in bright
colors on the front of the bag and in the back of the bag and in print that,
uh,
maybe a eight point,
it may be six point in size print that I have to take my glasses off and get
very close to you to be able to read.
The warnings are elead,
illegible,
uh,
and unintelligible to a very large proportion of society.
And there are some 12% of the u s population,
not an insignificant number in a population of 350,
310 million people.
So 10%,
uh,
that have no capacity to read type that is less than a 10 point and fun.
That means that those warning labels could never be effective for that
population.
If you add onto the,
uh,
that percentage,
the group that is illiterate,
uh,
the group that does not have enough education in order to understand how they
might,
uh,
what the risk is and how they might manage the risk.
Uh,
gradually you get up to a percentage as close to 40% of the US population does
not have the capacity to understand a message of hazard or the capacity to
interpret how to manage that hazard in a way that would cause the environment to
be protected or human health to be protected.
So the statutes we'll look at,
I'm not going to go through all of these now,
but,
uh,
we'll go through the,
the,
the major statutes,
uh,
and the,
the book Weinberg and Riley will give you a very concise,
quick overview of the key provision of these statutes.
Uh,
and I will show you how the statutes apply individually to the,
to the very,
uh,
the various cases.
Take a look not just at the chemical management statutes,
but also the federal land and Resource Management Statutes such as the
Wilderness Act,
the endangered species act,
the National Parks Service,
Organic Act,
and several others.
Additional crucial statutes that you might not think about as being
environmental in nature,
uh,
include patent law,
governing trade secrecy,
uh,
the freedom of Information Act.
Uh,
that gives you the right to,
to request from the government information,
uh,
about public policy or about,
the environment.
And I'll pause here and just ask,
how many of you have made requests under the freedom of Information Act to a
government agency?
It's very interesting.
The majority of people that do that in society,
uh,
are highly specialized.
They work in the private sector or their lawyers.
They're using MS basis for lawsuits.
Uh,
so the freedom of information act was intended to democratize information,
uh,
that was held inside a libraries and in government agencies.
But it's been highly ineffective in a variety of ways.
The National Security Act,
the war powers act,
the administrative procedures act,
Homeland Security,
the Patriot Act,
and different budget,
uh,
statutes as for ranging from subsidies to,
to,
uh,
authorizations for funding for EPA.
And these statutes are,
are absolutely crucial.
So you can imagine the,
uh,
law being passed,
that,
uh,
say,
let's say the law had the intent,
uh,
to protect,
the environment from a,
a new plastic compound so that,
uh,
that law might be plastic,
but might be passing that might demand a,
that the chemical,
uh,
be tested thoroughly.
Uh,
it might demand that it be labeled in a way that,
uh,
would ensure that,
it would be managed more effectively.
It,
it might be,
uh,
it might've signed penalties,
for deviance.
But in Congress,
if Congress doesn't allocate the money to EPA,
the program will fail.
So the industry recognizes this quite clearly,
that they have not lost the battle.
Uh,
if a law is passed,
uh,
they will have an opportunity year after year to go back to Congress and try to
block allocation for monitoring that issue.
Uh,
foreign forcing that issue.
and that explains a lot of the ineffectiveness of 20th century environmental
law.
So on Thursday we'll come back to a discussion about different types of
strategies to,
to protect the environment,
different decisions,
standards that are embedded in a different statutes.
Uh,
and we'll particularly take up this issue of distributional effects,
how some chemicals,
uh,
behave differently than others.
They result in exposures to some groups that are higher than others.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
thinking about how a costs,
as well as benefits are allocated quite differently in society by environmental
laws.
So I'm going to pause there and,
uh,
just take a couple of minutes for any questions that you got.
Yes.
Could you repeat that please?
Uh,
the,
after the lecture each day,
uh,
the lecture slides will be posted online.
Also,
I will use the,
the classes server quite regularly.
Uh,
some of the readings that you will have assigned to you will be on the class of
server.
Uh,
so that some of the discussion sections as well May,
may I use strategies to,
uh,
pose questions and,
require your responses on the class of server as well.
Yes.
Well,
I hold office hours.
I will hold office hours and I will announce those on Thursday.
Anything else?
Well,
thank you very much for joining me.